there's a a reporter for the atlantic
who blocked me recently
because uh i quote tweeted him in a
critical critical of the media in
general
but uh we're seeing something quite a
bit where they're saying there's this
this meme going around with the
journalists say
if uh the past four years of trump was
like drowning in a vat of tabasco sauce
then the next stories of biden will be
like sipping unflavored almond milk and
everyone laughs like haha joe biden is
going to be so
so boring right so joe biden hurts his
ankle
okay and this reporter for the atlantic
posts
an image saying joe biden playing with
dog hurts ankle and he says
you know an image of how boring the next
several years are going to be
and then he does this joke where it's
like 2019 donald trump extra
extra legally calls for an investigation
of saturday night live
because they made a critical you know
sketch about him 20 20 21 you know joe
biden plays with a dog
something like that so my response was
2011
barack obama orders drone strike on
civilian cafe and country we're not at
war with killing a 16 year old american
citizen and his response to the public
is oopsie
2020. joe biden's transition team is
looking a lot like barack obama's team
so we're going to get obama 2.0
point being journalists are basically
telling us they're not going to do their
jobs certainly
they're already saying it's so funny
playing with a dog meanwhile it's like
okay
should we count down the days until he
blows up some kids i mean it's like
that's
it's definitely a situation where you're
gonna have
them using oh there's a there's a rescue
pet
you know oh look at look at the funny
socks oh you know uh
tony blinken he he plays the guitar
that's the thing that we're going to
talk about the next secretary of state
and it's like shouldn't aren't there
more important things that are
going to need to be addressed here i
mean the most significant obviously
being
i still have no idea what joe biden's
secret planned
and the coronavirus looks like that one
of course he doesn't
it just seems to be yell on the phone
via you know at uh governors to have
more mass mandates now
we can play the the partisan game and i
can say i just read a story
that joe biden heard his ankle playing
with doug what is this man doing playing
with a dog during one of the most
the worst pandemics we've ever
experienced shouldn't he be working on
something instead of playing
around with you play silly games
criticize him for whatever you can
but that's that's like the the partisan
that's that's the partisan media
barack obama admits that he was smoking
throughout his entire tenure
at the white house some pot no no i wish
um but maybe you want to kill somebody
honestly it would probably been a much
better
piece pipe but but seriously
the the fact that we never knew that
when everyone was so
like picking apart uh trump's like i
think they always lie about the
president's help i always say he's
healthier i think jacob
jake tapper there's like something jake
tapper called him out and got ridiculed
for it
uh like years ago he said i smelled
smoke on obama and then they all made
fun of him i think it was tapper
and now he's like i do recall this yes
um but it's but it's like that's what
they're gonna do again
they're gonna totally because it's fine
a tan suit oh that was the only scandal
that was the right wasn't it that was
that was criticizing him so the tan suit
thing
uh is a total fake news fiction it's
like a handful of people made fun of the
tan suit
yeah and then everybody has now put like
the tan suit was this huge scandal on
the right
and it's like it was literally a hand i
remember jokes i remember interestingly
we have a uh
luke rodkowski is hanging out he was at
i think it was like a dna it was a
debate or something a dancy convention
and he asked a couple democrats about
the extrajudicial assassination by
barack obama of a 16 year old american
citizen
whose name was abdulrahman al-awlaki and
it was uh camera the guy's name's
charlie gibbs is that his name
he said well he should have had a better
father the so so so the questions that
arose
no no yeah seriously that is a hot take
a 16 year old american from denver
colorado lived in san diego
was visiting his grandparents in yemen
barack obama ordered a drone strike
in yemen we're not at war with yemen
blowing up a civilian restaurant
we don't target civilians killing a
six-year-old american citizen
what the target kids talk about somebody
that obama wanted dead right yeah he was
uh
uh suspected of being like a high high
profile like uh jihadist so the theory
is they killed
the guy's son well the the anti-war
activists think
that barack obama was basically telling
the world if you
f with us i will kill your kids and he's
willing to block civilians to do it it's
so funny how
though the media complex pretended
that trump's approach of foreign policy
was going to be
something that dragged him down that was
this negative around him
with the american people when it is so
much more historically in sync with what
americans tend to want
which is they they do they are not p
snicks okay they
they go through periods of after heavy
wards of being you know sort of looking
like peaceniks but in reality they tend
to be as walter russell mead is written
consistently jacksonian which is that if
you leave us alone and you don't screw
with us
then we won't do we don't want to go
over there and screw with you and have
it come back and you know
have it be complicated and that kind of
thing uh we just want you to leave us
alone but if you screw with us we're
going to come over and we're just going
to you know
and we're armed beat the crap out of you
for some
and more and and that's what they like
but then they don't like to
stay around and exist in these
nation-building ways
and in fact george w bush made that same
argument when he was running for
president in 2000 he said
we don't want to be in the
nation-building business anymore that
type of thing wow
exactly that's how it worked out for him
um go back
and find that clip well but i think that
that's another indication where
there is a that is the undercurrent
because it's actually pretty consistent
with frankly a lot of people who come
from military families
want it's the fact that they don't want
their kid to be sent over to some small
war they understand the purpose of
defending america
they're patriots they want the country
to be defended they don't want to
you know get rid of the military or you
know shut that all down
at the same time they don't want to hear
about their kid
dying in africa as we saw you know
a little more than a year ago and have
senators come on the camera and say
i didn't even know that we were in this
part of africa you know and that's what
happened and it's like
that should disgust us we should never
have a situation where that happens it's
the first time i've heard of that you
know you know
we had uh we had a lefty on the show and
he was like 26.
we were talking about joe biden's you
know as a vice president in these
scandals
and he was like i think i was 15 or 16
when that happened so
so a lot of these totally and and i'm
experiencing this now because i am an
old man
at 38. um and uh and i have employees
now
who were you know two years old when 9
11
yeah three years old uh and uh you know
they don't even
you know when when one of my colleagues
makes a reference to team america world
police and they have no idea what he's
talking about
which is really depressing it's like
what you're all doing what is this
puppet sex move
that you're talking about anyway
familiar
the only way i would sleep with you is
if you promised me you would never die i
will never
die the the thing that is
amazing about it is you start to see how
uh and i didn't listen to people who
were older than me and who told me this
our politics repeats so much it has this
rhyming quality to it
where we come back to these same points
with new figures
and new elements but they also repeat in
these fascinating ways
and you know oftentimes i think you end
up having these
controversial in the time figures who in
retrospect
prove to be viewed as incredibly
effective or having done
amazing things you know reagan was one
of these figures
clinton became one of these figures i
think in retrospect people look back and
they're like wow that bill clinton he
was you know
very centrist and sort of did these
cultural culturally slightly
conservative things and
you know had these attitudes in
different directions at the time he was
the most controversial person
we'd ever seen in the presidency and
republicans
hated him and loathed him and
investigated the crap out of him and
impeached him
and i think in in retrospect we'll
look back we'll come to look back on
trump as being a similar figure in a lot
of respects
he governed closer to the center than
people actually many people are saying
you know how many uh months or years
until
ellen is you know sharing candy with
trump at a baseball game or something
soon but i think it'll be biden first
well look george w bush in that famous
you know bit with saying the candy who
will it be who will it be
because it won't be somebody who's
conservative like vince vaughn it'll be
someone who's a little bit
more who will it be it's it's
crazy to me that if you look at the
things george w bush did and dick cheney
compared to what trump did
it's just like night and day and here
they are there was a poll that came out
that said democrats view
george w bush more favorably than trump
and i'm like y'all have lost oh my gosh
but this is why i just don't know but
listen no no this is why i brought up
the dude yes but when you have when you
have people who are
you got 20 year olds who voted 20 year
olds who are activists online right
online right now marching down the
street right there waving better that's
when we got into iraq
yeah and there were ten they were they
were they were they were
uh what eight years old during the
economic crisis
they were 10 years old in 2010 they were
11 during occupy wall street
so while we're on occupy wall street and
you've got the left rising up
complaining about
obama and both democrats and republicans
and we got all of these years look the
the emergence of black lives matter and
all this stuff happened under obama
the national guard being deployed all of
it's under obama we had these riots
we had uh you know libya syria all of
these conflicts
you have stories about drone strikes
they called him obama
obamber like bombing people they called
him the deporter in chief
here we are we get trump not good in the
first few years in foreign policy
improving
very much so in the in the last two
years firing bolton especially bringing
up all the time it was a great move
shouldn't hire them in the first place
and then i'm talking to these these
people who are now in their 20s and
they're like
i was 10 when all that was happening and
i'm like so you you come into my house
we've been fighting this fight against
these insane these insane people you
know
hillary clinton was told a no-fly zone
over syria would mean world war three
war with russia and she was like
basically so what
so you know what you just touched on
there is is one of the
the great ironies of trump's presidency
which is that
uh to the degree that it was a failure
um
it is because he failed to do the very
thing he was most famous for
before coming into the presidency which
is fire people oh yes
if he had fired james comey on day one
oh yeah you don't have all of that
you i don't trust that he trusts too
many people if if
if you fire or never hire bolton you
don't have that period
if you fire anthony fauci the minute
that he comes out and says we're not
we shouldn't reopen schools despite the
rest of the first world
reopening schools uh i mean there's a
lot of different things that could have
gone
right here if trump had been quicker to
fire people as
if he had and if he had actually been
almost if he would if it was even an one
one degree towards more authoritarian as
much as they claim him to be but
and in addition it's the funny thing is
that that's the actual
i would argue the same thing of george w
bush you know uh
michael brown and katrina you know heck
of a job brownie
he should have fired him almost
immediately as it became clear that he
was not cut out to run
fema in this situation you know he he
declined
firing rumsfeld you know when rumsfeld
was willing to go
like there's a number of instances where
he kind of stuck with people out of
personal loyalty
and it ended up backfiring i just think
that this is
it's again it's one of those situations
where things rhyme
and people people end up getting
cowardice bush was a coward he had
cheney around the military
trump's a coward he doesn't he wants
people to like him so he won't make hard
decisions i wouldn't necessarily say
cowardice it's more there's
we forget sometimes that politicians are
human
and i think that one of the things that
animates them so much it's similar to
actors
no offense to mr page is that they have
this deep
hole in their heart that needs to be
filled with something whether that's
adulation or praise or affirmation i
mean there's a reason that so many great
politicians have parents who are drunks
that describes donald trump he puts his
name in giant gold letters and types of
buildings all over the world
yeah and the joke is that you know his
he was neglected
i mean the left argues he was literally
abused he was letting bolton
run the show until he saw that people
hated him on twitter he's like uh oh
gotta get rid of him so people like me
so the american conservative wrote
fire bolton hire tulsi and i was
clapping i'm like yes
like absolutely get rid of this guy but
i think that this is a
situation where once again we we now
have a
a political situation that is dominated
by the olds by the people who have
nothing in common with all the people
who you were just talking
about yep we have we had three
presidents from the same birth year
1946 okay it had it had george w bush it
had bill clinton and it had donald trump
they were all born
within seven months of each other and um
and if you think about it they're all
kind of the different aspects of
boomerism
yeah like clinton the kind of you know
hippie higher ed you know draft dodger
you know george w kind of the the
miscreant like the guy who kind of had a
rough time but then kind of made good
frat boy yeah and then trump is kind of
the rat pack
you know hold over you know over-the-top
vegas you know
where are the young people in this in
this you know well we just went over
we just went to our first silent
generation era we went older
than the baby boom he snapped his foot
playing with his dog
seriously no no no no no listen i'm
gonna say it again joe biden is the
worst thing to happen to this country
for like listen there's a lot of i'm
sure joe's fine in a lot of ways he's
bad a lot of ways
but for what this country is going
through right now the worst possible
thing that could happen is joe biden you
know why because he's free
every every republican hates him or or
for the most part doesn't like him
and half the democrats don't like him he
only got elected
arguably from the right they'll say
because of fraud but in the surface
level approach
people voted against trump yes against
trump meaning at a time when we are more
polarized than ever and we need strong
leadership to unite us
what we get is nothing we have no
president we have no
voted dude i i really i really say this
with
hope that it is not true but the worst
president in american
history in my pers from my perspective
is james buchanan and obviously
he led to a long time ago can you
explain why
james buchanan was was a feckless and uh
corrupt sort of guy who you know really
was
completely unprepared for the kind of
strife that was coming in
into the country ultimately he was
obviously followed by abraham lincoln
and we immediately went into civil war
because of it now i'm not predicting
that and i want to make clear that i'm
not predicting that but this
it has a similar flavor to it of someone
who is just
elected in in for a lot of reasons that
don't have to do with him and then
shows himself to be very ill-suited for
the historic moment that he inhabits
and i really worry that that's what
we're facing right now
maybe donald trump convinces look
pennsylvania says they're not going to
come into session
they say we need five days for a joint
resolution maybe trump
gets a lightning strike three times
georgia maybe
wisconsin and arizona but guess what you
know it's really interesting no one's
that lucky in the casino
i i look i i've been saying it since the
seventh
like i think it's astronomically likely
it's going to be i i shouldn't say that
i shouldn't say it that way
the odds extremely in joe biden's favor
to the point where it's like 99.99
but the reason i reserve that little bit
actually early on i said it was probably
like 97
because trump still had these lawsuits
and he still had the states weren't
certified
now we're at a point where it's like
winning the lottery three times in a row
for trump to pull it off but i'm not but
i wouldn't ever but i wouldn't say never
i wouldn't say never
because listen listen we had these
hearings okay and people are freaked out
it doesn't mean it's likely at all it
just means the door
the the here's the way i put it there's
a track
that trump is on at the end of that
there's a gleam men
yes there's a train track trump's train
is on it and it is headed towards a door
that means
re-election but in between are
loop-de-loops jumps boulders
trees falling over and it's like i don't
see it making there
maybe have you extremely unlikely have
you looked back at the election of 1876
yes yes that was when they appointed a
council to determine the president it
was amazing
absolutely crazy but it also puts in
perspective how like
i know 1876 seems like a long time ago
but that's just shows
like our american bodies 150 years you
know like
like there are people who are who are
walking around who's like
that was their grandpa who was around
you know during like the presidency
well i was i was listening to the radio
once and it was a beer commercial it was
an import and they were like
our beer is protected by the you know
fine beer law of 1217 and i was like
wow like the united states doesn't go
back that far you know
we are so incredibly young as a nation
dude i was just thinking
in order for us to have a normal
conversation just talk about this stuff
we have to have our own social network
it has to be a mesh network so we don't
have an isp
we have to be on the banking system and
have crypto only
because the banks can all shut us down
we have to have our own electricity on
site
and our own water supply on site because
the government can shut off our water
and well
but just to have a normal conversation
publicly but listen if you if you
if you actually you know these people
the green new deal types and the
leftists
everything you describe should be
exactly what they're striving for
get people off the grid so that they're
self-sustainable get people
why do we have lawns just grass and then
we do we mow the grass and we throw it
in a compost
what if you turn your front lawn into a
potato field and you have then you have
food you don't have to grow
potatoes you can go buy stuff with
crypto but if you can't
turn your crypto into cash fiat because
you don't have a bank
i i won swift payment system has cut you
out
has banned your person right right right
and if and if we all became more
self-sufficient that would have less of
an impact on us
if we could grow our own food if we had
our own energy on our homes
just so you can talk without being
censored but do you think that the
do you think though that the the
lockdowns and everything have been
have improved the possibility of that or
no it decreased
yeah it's it's now you got people saying
government why won't you give me free
food
exactly exactly like i got a guard in my
backyard you know uh look we moved
i moved out to the middle of nowhere
because i don't want to be
forced to live under their boot when
they start locking you down
telling you can and can't go to the
store you can't go out at night you
eventually run out of the limited food
you have living in the city and then
you're just sitting there saying please
government can i now eat
okay can i can i speak to that the so i
was born in mississippi grew up a little
bit in south carolina and then we moved
to rural virginia which is actually
about
you know an area where uh
before the big tech boom
before all of these companies moved in
it was all rural farmland
and farmland that was starting to be
chopped up into into
suburbs but still homes that had tons of
land and the like
and living in that area you were
surrounded by
two types of people um you know a very
rural area basically it was people who
their families had lived there for ages
they were used to being
incredibly self-sufficient you know when
winter came if they were up you know
sort of in the blue ridge they could you
know live up there and be fine for ages
and then you had these people who were
moving there often from california and
the like
to staff these jobs at then it was aol
and mci worldcom and places like that
that were the first ones coming in and
the differences between the kids
could not have been greater in terms of
expectations about
life and what was self-sufficiency and
things like that and seeing the early
stages
of like helicopter parenting as a trend
at the same time that there were
families where it was like oh yeah the
little kid they'll just go off and
they'll take care of themselves and
they'll come back
total divide and i feel like as a
country we're seeing
that helicopter approach just
completely take over and the and the
worry that i've had and i've said this
since this whole thing began i had a
conversation with a friend of mine
who does a great podcast called the
fifth column
and we were going back and forth and he
said you know i'm worried that we're
gonna see
revolution we're gonna see people with
guns in the streets
you know and that they're gonna be
fighting and killing politicians and
things and like
i said my worry is they're just going to
go along with all this
because the american people are too
docile now they don't have that
self-sufficiency gene anymore it's been
smothered
and i just think that everything that's
happened since it's vindicated thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you